[Music]
meu sup news submitted by which the me
from the land down and gasps oh oh good
a karaoke party turned deadly after a
man went on a stabbing spree for being
boom not away that's crazy
ya know like my [ __ ] finger will [ __ ]
you dead [ __ ] so Wolverine was out
karaoke and it's art going on they start
stabbing the [ __ ] out of people I want
to know what's on Dara Singh because
what is it like baby hit my wife it's
kind of like the most ridiculous or
softest love song and then you just died
yeah must have been a vulnerable one I
think I'm picturing him just dancing
Oslo I don't wanna live without you what
[ __ ] you but something I meant a lot to
him
so this man name is when not dip and
he's bitten amazing damn you do not [ __ ]
with a Vietnamese guy during karaoke
time though that's their [ __ ] I kill you
yeah they have that [ __ ] like extra
reverb II and if you have a Vietnamese
family that live near you you'll hear it
every Sunday family time and that [ __ ]
is really really loud here's what this
much dislike this thing ha ha ha sadly
they be doing that Paris by night [ __ ]
so this does take place in South Vietnam
and this was happening during a wedding
oh come on with your guests or an actual
family member after I wonder - no - I
just know that he was stabbing at the
wedding party that's all I know
driving away you don't have weekend urge
another stab you at the wedding
how was the wedding you know Michelle
wedding all yeah just understaffing
everybody that you know Barbara lady
when when was on the stage he was
singing and apparently he was so bad
that a guest jumped onstage with him
microphone what it [ __ ] started
mocking his thing oh you can't do that I
might be like Vietnamese communist
general yeah that's crazy in the head
yeah so then the two of them started
arguing please what the [ __ ] man you
suck man you sir this is you okay silent
night I can display ecstatically he
doesn't make a mess boys to men and
Christmas off to poison your mash up
yeah and it's like hey don't tell me
what to do I dedicate this song for
Michelle [ __ ] yo man give me those you
can sing for [ __ ]
that's what happened and an argument
started happened and a third person came
into the mix Oh a third person yeah mr.
pham they was Lee hung on okay he tried
to stop her the argument be some
responsibility this is a wedding guy
yeah and so we both look at Susie so in
this third vengeance and that's when the
he got stabbed and bad several times
oh my god she just had a pocketknife
like ready to go yeah so it was actually
when that started stabbing the guy with
that took the microphone and the guy
that jumped in to stop the whole fight
now and so that guy that jumped in to
stop Lee hung on he later died oh my god
yeah imagine it's your [ __ ] wedding
it's your day and someone's getting
stabbed the guy who smashed the
microphone he is still in the hospital
and when he has been arrested was he
under the influence so they are
reporting that usually at these weddings
there is a lot of alcohol involved but
it hasn't been reported whether or not
they were drunk
the stabbing that's kind of crazy I
thought that was like gangster Ben Damis
wedding out here in California cause
it's kind of like the same my friend
he's been amis I'm not going to say no
names though but his race should tell
you all that he loves to fight our
weddings what yeah he always gets into
finally like Mike Hill picked a fight no
maybe it's other guys that are
like-minded and they just like to any
party
he saw this invited to parties weddings
I think they just love fighting all the
time I'll invite that guy we were gonna
get a fight I went to one recently and
told me during the reception he got into
a fight fair after all your friends yeah
Kiki witnessed him getting into a fight
and I was like oh there goes that same
old buddy that I knew since high school
fighting everybody I just like this
faster do they get more extreme dislikes
that was sex for the wedding so they're
not gonna escalate beyond a fistfight
you're gonna what about their guns and
their knives there is the guns in that
hey what is it with weddings in fist
fights I don't know maybe it's just
putting together a bunch of family
members that you can't [ __ ] stand and
you're forced to be at a table with the
male I should hook up oh and then if it
is you up I don't want to fistfight out
your guys exciting I didn't invite
anybody that's a weirdo what did we fish
white out your wedding no you better not
I think it's like alcohol to any people
they drink they start getting crazy
right into like a member of one time and
then you're like to push them on death -
oh yeah that's probably what happened
and you'll focus on some men what you
hurt my feeling man so something with
the head
you don't like my rendition of oyster
bed Sally nice
I don't explain what do I do to you
because you know I crave hey that's not
the way I go they got into an argument
when you guys attend two weddings you
guys because there's like a lot of love
in the air because like there's two
people that really love and care for
each other I actually like going to be
together forever talk about the
reception or the ceremony and so then
when you when you see your I Do's right
like as like a couple that hasn't been
married like during those times I guess
you guys ever feel the pressure to
actually I think about marriage with
like your partner or did you guys like
just have a lot of like insecurities
flaw I don't like about me cuz I
remember sitting there with Jess and I
was like my friends boy and Jill are
getting married and look at Bart's mom
she's so happy and wash I think there's
no time at allit it is just like that I
feel like those long ceremony yeah um I
feel like growing up I went to a lot of
weddings yeah but from high school and
on there's this time when you just don't
go well maybe for me because when you're
part of like I don't know like a church
and all that stuff you go to a lot of
weddings but then I just stopped going
so in my adult life I haven't
experienced many weddings you know the
child room because like I hear on like
both spectrums like guys and girls were
like if they go with like their
boyfriend or the girlfriend to wedding
like they kind of feel the pressure of
oh man like I should really start
thinking about getting there but I want
to be married with this person do you
guys go to weddings as a couple I never
thought about it this one yeah but I
think like I don't know like for me like
I think I know my past and what I want
to do and I know how I feel about or
whatever so I never like feel that way
like I don't see my friend buy a house
and we all got to buy a house so like I
see them graduate and I go all maybe I
gotta graduate like I just I got my
stuff I gotta do and then I just told
her to support them but it never really
affected me or made me think
I only try to keep up with the Joneses
when I watch porn what part of the porn
I'm like oh what what is she doing I
need to get that dog like what
like that's pretty cool they use a pizza
man and he had a dick to his pizza man
that's a lot of money to spend and
you're gonna get your dick all cheesed
up I don't know about that but maybe
I'll try it one day maybe I said yeah
like I want to do it too that's the only
time I get like oh that's happening I
want to do - that makes no it's not when
you see people ice cream all they bring
that dogs very go to BG always saying oh
those things little things yet but big
things in my life I kind of already have
my own plan so it doesn't really get
affected by little stuff like if I'm on
my diet and some guy eats ice cream
around me I'm like you try to keep up
with the Joneses life yeah I think the
only time I had that thought crossed my
mind at a wedding was when I caught the
bouquet oh that looks like a Saracen
your mags were you
I don't know those Casey's friends from
Dallas I don't know if anyone got
married that was there every time a
booty came my way I was like ooh uh did
you try to catch it or you were you like
just put your hands out and just happen
to fall into them yeah those like that I
mean like dive for it or like push
people out or just like there's some
girls like that though yeah I see that
[ __ ] I'm alive you thirsty thirsty ass
[ __ ]
you know you weird I hope you guys
enjoyed this video for more please
subscribe to our Channel and you can
check out the last video right here
[Music]